the tension is certainly mounting among
the stars backstage dr. Doolittle in the
house lassie needs a sedative to present
the next Awards we welcome that fine
actor and member of the Academy's Board
of Governors mr. MacDonald Carey who
escorts one of the world's most elegant
beauties miss Diahann Carroll
Diane I'm gonna kneel for a while dear
folks I think they want us to work and
pray at the same time I'm not sure we
have the other we have the boom out here
let's have the boom boom
hi Diane everybody is talking about your
new television series for next here we
are
yeah
Dian Dian everybody's talking about you
on the 40 of mine we pick it up all
right well we have to me I am everybody
is talking about your new television
series for next season I want to
congratulate you thank you Bob I'm
looking forward to playing my first real
comedy yeah we're so mine what's the
name by what line Bob well it's what's
the name of your series diet
I've never worked to the basement before
that's all I've determined to tell you
about we call it Julia and I'm certainly
hoping that it will be a success Julia
yeah well I'll go out and light a candle
the Saint Nielsen thank you goodbye Bob
here we are well there are two
categories the short subject awards for
the best achievement in live-action
short subjects the nominations are
paddle to the sea produced by Julian
Biggs
a place to stand produced by Christopher
Chapman sky Overhaulin produced by John
fair no stop look and listen
produced by Len Johnson and Chuck mango
will you announce the winner mr. Carey
thank you the winner is a place to stand
mist of attack
well well on behalf of the Ontario
government and David Makai of TDF and
Barry Gordon and the very many people
who have made this film so successful I
thank you very very very much indeed
or the best achievement in khartoum
short subjects there are three
nominations the box Fred wolf producer
he put a is beta John Shaw's Mooney air
producer what on earth
Robert Farrell and wolf caning produces
would you tell us the winner miss Carol
the winner is a box read wall
Thank You Shelley Shelley man musician
who did this
rich Harrison my son Billy wolf My
partner and I are very happy Academy
thank you thank you very much
because because of her brilliance is a
cloud some of us are apt to forget for a
moment that Martha Raye is capable of
instilling a lyric with warmth through a
dramatic scene with humanity the heart
for this capable of such honesty is the
one we have enlisted to read a message
to the membership of the Academy ladies
and gentlemen miss Martha Raye
on this occasion of your 40th annual
awards for achievement it is appropriate
to express a deep gratitude of every
American in military service for the
tremendous contribution the
entertainment energy has made similar
response to requests for continuing flow
of top stars entertainment unison has
been immediate warm and enthusiastic
I wish particularly to command the USO
Hollywood overseas committee without its
untiring efforts we could not meet the
critical need this program is designed
to serve he's expressed my personal
thanks to the fine and attainers we're
visited my command and two others will
arrive in the future
sincerely WC Westmoreland general United
States Army